L'histoire de leur migration
passe souvent inaperçue.
Mais pour une fois, leur
parcours et leurs visages sontnt
sortis de l'ombre.
Des élèves en classes
de francisation dans trois
écoles secondaires de Longueuil
t des textes.
SAMUEL GIRALDO ALONSO, élève,
École secondaire Saint-Edmond
- De écrire notre premièrejourn,
notre pays et notre opinion
sur le... monde.
- Arrivé de Colombie l'an
dernier, Samuel se fait bien
comprendre en francais.
- Ça fait juste, pas exactement
un an que je suis en classe
d'accueil, je sais pas comment
je fais.
Ça c'est mon livre que
j'ai écrit. Ça s'appelle:
"Une feuille et un crayon."
Ça c'est mon texte à moi,
qui je s
Ça c'est le texte que je vais
lire.
Mais le mauvais gouvernement a
créé la pauvreté lpauvreté lpaus
quatre ans et les conséquences
sont l'insécurité et le vol.
- Plus de 90 élèves ont écrit
toire et certains ont
accepté de la lire en public.
- Je viens de Jordanie.
- Je viens de la Colombie.
aucoup.
- Pour le moment, je suis
en classe d'accueil. Merci.
(applaudissements)- Ils sont fis
ont écrit et fiers de ce qu'ils
ont vécu aussi.
- Cet enseignant en classe
d'accueil est admi
PHILIPPE GEORGIADES, ens. franc.
École sec. Jacques-Rousseau
- C'est l'ouverture, la soif
d'apprendre. Chaque année
la plupart des élèves
me demandent: "Monsieur quand
est-ce que je vais parler
québécois?" "Quand est-ce que
je vais aller au régulier?"
C'est leur but.
- Se donner l'opportunité
de vivre au Québec, à nous
et à nos enfants, c'est quelque
chose d'inexplicab
J'ai pas les mots.
- Des adultes en classe
de francisation ont également
participt Voix
Migrantes. Edivan Battista a
voulu parler des deuils qu'il a
faits en quittant le Brésil
mois.
EDIVAN BATISTA, élève en classe
d'accueil École Camille-Laurin
- Émotif beaucoup et je pleurebs
d'écrire.
- Parfois ça rappelle, des
souvenirs, un deuil qu'il
fallait faire, un arrachement,
des racines qu'il faut replanter
de nouveau. Puis tout ça c'est
comme une aventure à revivre
à travers l'écriture.
- Les invités ont pu lire
les textes sur leur téléphone.
MOUNIA HACIB, enseignante
École Camille-Laurin
CHARLÈNE OUELLETTE coordo.,
Centre services Marie-Victorin
- Je me sens aussi extrêmement
r accès
à toutes ces histoires de vie
là que les élèves ont eu
la générosité de partager
un morceau de leur histoire
s.
- On a vraiment intérêt
à partager dans des événements
comme celui qu'on vit
aujourd'hui, de leur donnerla pt
un peu ce qu'ils vivent et qu'on
développe de la compassion
pour leur realité.
- Je m'appelle Pauline et
j'ai écris un Slam pour toutes
les femmes.
- On compte bien répéter
l'expérience qui a engendré
de la fierté et de l'espoir.
- Ne perd jamais espoir, ne
baisse jamais les bras. Femme
forte tu es et tu resteras
toujours. Merci à ces femmes.(a)
- Et qui aura aussi peut-être
bâti des ponts. Ici Anne-Louisee
Radio-Canada, Lon